[music]
may everything be well,
remember God, she went to work, she
returned, that’s how everything is. The crew supports each other
so that everything is fine.
The battle for Donetsk continues.
the state continues,
even though the enemy has concentrated most of its
forces. Our soldiers, the
armed forces of Ukraine, are in this direction. All defense and
security forces are protecting the state.
24 days of full-scale war. And how has everything
changed for Russia, they are already
gnawing among themselves over who to attribute
some tactical advancement  a clear
signal of failure for the enemy and this is another
incentive for all of us to put more pressure on the
occupier and to inflict more
losses on the enemy. I thank everyone who ensures this both
on the front line and on all our other
fronts
in general thanks to the negotiations this week
We managed to significantly strengthen the determination of our
partners  to increase the supply of weapons
to Ukraine